l'iran veut tel se doter de l'armé
nucléaire c'est un soupçon anciens ils
remontent à la révolution islamique de
1979 l'iran s'était alors tourné vers le
bloc soviétique pour développer son
programme nucléaire présentée comme
civil et non militaire
cette version va sion 2003 les premiers
indices sérieux alerte l' agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique
aiea sous l'égide de l'onu c'est elle
qui régule usage du nucléaire dans le
monde
les résultats ont montré la présence de
particules d'uranium hautement enrichi
alors comme vous savez l'uranium
hautement enrichi est un des éléments
qui permet de construire des armes
atomiques 2005 la situation se dégrade
mahmoud ahmadinejad est élu à la tête de
l'iran il dément toute visée militaire
mais sa version est contredite de
l'intérieur
deux ex salariés du nucléaire exilés
font des révélations selon le 3 site
produirait de l'uranium enrichi
je suis persuadé que l'iran possède déjà
la technologie nécessaire pour une
simple bombe atomique
pour moi ça ne fait aucun d'autres c'est
absolument indiscutable la suite un
va-et-vient pendant dix ans l'onu sur
une initiative des états unis
sanctionnent à coude embargo et l'iran
dément toujours nouvelles sanctions
contre l'iran
nous ne voulons pas ne boudons pas la
seule à rester la seule issue qu'il nous
reste c'est de faire pression sur l'iran
le conseil de sécurité de l'onu et
l'organisation la moins démocratiques du
monde 2015 la fin du ping pong avec
l'élection de hassan rohani le nouveau
président iranien ouvre la voie au
dialogue avec les américains basés fait
que certains pensent qu'il faut pour
faire la guerre au monde où capituler
devant les super puissances mais il y à
une troisième voie coopérer avec le
monde un accord est signé
l'iran affirme qu'elles renoncent aux
deux tiers de ces installations
d'enrichissement d'uranium et se soumet
au contrôle de l'onu
aujourd'hui les états unis avec
et partenaires ont conclu un accord
historique avec l'iran s'il est
complètement respecté il empêchera
l'iran de se doter de l'arme atomique
un accord historique et trois ans plus
tard un rétropédalage tout aussi majeur
donald trump annuler l'accord signé par
son prédécesseur
j'ai depuis les relations entre l'iran
et les états unis sont de plus en plus
tendue l'iran semble s'affranchir de la
corde 2015 à son tour ce qui inquiète
l'agencé de l'énergie atomique
[Musique]